merci marco merci marc antoine alors
aujourd'hui pour répondre à une
cérémonie récente on va organiser notre
propre aux cérémonies de la télévision
ça s'appelle les kevin ne touche pas à
mon poste on commence par la catégorie
meilleur jeu de mots et pour remettre le
kelly non reçoit un spécialiste laurent
wauquiez bonsoir bonsoir à tous
dans la catégorie meilleur jeu de mots
les trois nominés sont thierry moreau
avec sa blague sur jean michel maire
toi tu jouais pas du djembé tu jouais du
jam beat deuxième nominé thierry moreau
avec son calembours sur michel onfray
on ferait bien de regarder michel à la
télé et le dernier domine et thierry
moreau avec sa valve sur la chanteuse
stahl talent arrives tu à l'heure et le
gagnant est
suspense tiens c'est qu'ils pence
lugano est donc thierry mots
et si certains désignent départ par
offre départ pas à nous on offre des
briques des briques à l'oeuvre bien sûr
plaisir donc vous aurez votre briquet
tribaux alors maintenant au kevin du
moment le plus hypnotique ans avec un
rom étant assez particulier puisque
c'est notre président françois hollande
oui je bonjour dans la catégorie moment
le plus
jimdo tisot il me dodji sont donc de
vider remy epinoux les menottes isr et
gilles verdez pour pato pato est
également dominée isabelle morini-bosc
lorsqu'elle peut plonger toute une salle
dans le sommeil y racontant une anecdote
d'ailleurs moi aussi je suis innocent
ils misent auteurs bon si je fais de la
magie oui en deux en or deux ans j'ai
réussi à faire disparaître l'emploi et
la croissance
et le gagnant est isabelle morini bosc
bravo isabelle revers très bizarre
ça doit faire très bizarre de gagner
quelque chose de moi je sais pas ça
m'est jamais arrivé allez pour remettre
le kevin suivant celui de la
chroniqueuse la plus sexy je reçois je
n'aurai que the glory chroniqueuse à
plus sexy sont nominés et non malagré
isabelle morini bosc et christophe
carrière la gagnante
christophe c'est beau ça s'est distingué
un peu comme tout ces miss france qui se
sentent obligés de déballer leur chemin
ces petites traînait là qui s'enlise de
yaourt qui se veut c'est bon merci va
bien et l'on passe au kevin dupire
costumes et ses cales la karl lagerfeld
team à l'européenne
bonjour à tous je ne peux pas allé par
quatre chemins elle est nominée pour ce
pire costumes sont thierry moreau pour
ce costume de faucheuse qui fait froid
dans le dos il gardait pour ce costume
le dracula plus vrai que nature et cyril
hanouna pour ses costumes cyril hanouna
on sait on ose dire vêtements pour cette
frusques à la couleur qu'on qualifiera
de lax active du temps de jeu ne sais
quel e s puma de matières fécales
après la couleur caca d'oie à la couleur
non merci
et maintenant l'heure c'est maintenant
l'heure du kevin de la meilleure chuter
si c'est un spécialiste mondial qui va
la remettre c'est philippe candeloro
c'est sûr que à la cheville je connais
un juste passé les trois quarts du temps
sur le fion sur la glace elle par contre
maintenant je suis plus spécialiste de
la chute de reins ont les nominés pour
la meilleure chute sans enora malagré et
son fameux salto sur le caillou
retrouver isabelle morini bosc qui se
fait casser les pattes arrière par
obélix et bien sûr
gilles verdez et son saut de la mort
et le gagnant est gagnant et gilles
verdez
on peut dire que t'as pas flipper et qui
étaient jetés à l'eau un content d'avoir
gagné gilles j'ai mal j'ai mal à mon
kevina j'ai mal à mon briquet bras allez
on passe au kevin du meilleur pas qui va
être remis par jean marc généreux à la
vraie main sic alors qu'un la mort les
nominés pour le meilleur pas ça thierry
moreau pour pas de vannes christophe
carrière pour pas de coiffeur bernard
montiel pour passer quand 9 mai 58 ans
et enora malagré % pas ddas on regarde
c'est comme si cela n'existait pas et ça
s'arrête là dernier quart des danaïdes
et kevin une des plus prestigieuses et
elle est présenté par jean luc reichmann
que c'est encore que sur deux cas c'est
ok dans la catégorie chroniqueur le
mieux monter sont nominés jean-luc
lebron parce que ses questions qu'a
tiers sont très bien monté gilles verdez
qui est très bien monté sur la grue
jean-michel moeurs et celui qui reporte
de kevin chroniqueur le mieux monter et
jean michel meyer bien sûr et tout ça
sans montage vidéo et sans grue au jour
à bercy jean luc reichmann dans les
traitements et adam un nom pour les
quais ville de tpm que vous allez
refaire
voilà et bab el had en un an paul et
kevin au tpc je dis merci
tous les mercredis